tropical storm Cristobal is growing
stronger as it churns towards the Gulf
Coast the storm has already caused
massive mudslides in Mexico and Central
America Louisiana's governor has
declared a state of emergency as
Cristobal threatens to make landfall
late Sunday or early Monday in New
Orleans some businesses place sandbags
in front of doors meteorologist Jeff
bird Ellie has more Jeff good morning
hey good morning Dana and good morning
everybody so yeah we are talking about
the third name system of this very young
hurricane season I mean it's only the
beginning of June looking at the storms
track this is gonna be taking a track
towards Louisiana we think it's probably
gonna make landfall on Sunday night
likely with winds around 60 miles an
hour right now the winds are 45 so it is
gonna be strengthening watch out around
Grand Isle watch out around New Orleans
up to around Baton Rouge and anywhere
east of the system is where the worst
it's going to be looking at future radar
the rain begins to break out later today
especially in bands at first on and off
but eventually as we head into tomorrow
we're gonna start to see that rain
become heavier and steadier tomorrow
night very heavy rain in the
southeastern part of Louisiana all the
way east to Mobile Alabama but even
western Florida around Tampa is going to
get some heavy rain bands as well the
bigger story is the rain however we do
want to talk about the wind it's gonna
be getting stronger as the system moves
towards the north and where you see the
white we're gonna see wind gusts over 50
miles an hour so there will be some
places especially in New Orleans
eastward so Grand Isle into Mobile and
Biloxi you'll likely see some wind gusts
over 50 a few places probably eclipsing
65 70 miles an hour but by far the
biggest issue is going to be the rain
and the flooding from that we're likely
gonna see about four to six inches in
general of rainfall right here in
Southeast Louisiana and into Mississippi
and Alabama some places picking up over
a foot of rain and in the eastern part
of Louisiana and along the coast of
Mississippi we could see up to around 3
to 5 feet of storm surge flooding if you
were right near the water so this is not
a catastrophic hurricane but it is going
to be impactful and I urge you to take
caution especially if you're asked to
evacuate an area that could see storm
surge flooding Jeff